so i think really as long as they don't
do anything stupid like for example put
him in a ridiculous wig they should be
fine
[Laughter]
nina as our resident game of thrones
expert
what are the biggest mistakes that house
of the dragon can avoid
well luckily it looks like they've
already avoided the biggest one which is
don't hire
david benioff and d.b weiss to do
absolutely anything at all those men
have personally betrayed me and millions
of other people and they will be held
responsible can you give us a quick a
quick recap as to what's making you say
that yeah so they started out on a
pretty promising foot i still think the
first season of game of thrones is one
of the better seasons of television i've
ever watched it builds to a really
satisfying point you know i don't think
i need to put a spoiler warning over the
fact that they kill the guy you think is
the lead of the show right nine episodes
in like this is 10 years old if you
haven't if you don't know this by now
i'm i'm sorry i can't help you um
sorry and so you know that
they had they also had george r martin's
books for the first
i believe it's five seasons
because i think season six is when they
had to kind of strike it on their own
and i like season six i think more than
most
really hardcore book fans uh i've only
read the books once um right and i have
read them but i've only read them once
all the way through
and so once they ran out of territory
they started to stumble a little bit and
it seems like they probably could have
stuck the landing and it also seems like
they had the ending of daenerys going
crazy and then you know
somebody having to kill her
that someone eventually being jon snow
seems like that could have all happened
reasonably it seems like killing the
night king could have happened
reasonably it seems like everything that
did happen in the final season could
have happened reasonably but instead it
happened in a very rushed six episodes
where everything just happened all at
once with
very little buildup and right almost
every character arc was just run
directly into the ground
it felt like their parking meter was
running out yeah and it was like
on a show where
right because they wanted to do their
star war and now they don't have a star
war anymore so way to go
um because catherine kennedy probably
took one look at that season and was
like and just fired them um
and like you know for a show where the
first three or four seasons were like
the central thesis was like man it takes
so long to get everywhere
then people were just
ripping huge holes in the space-time
continuum and traveling across this
entire
you know fictional continent in like an
hour and a half
um
well five minutes in show time but i
think we were supposed to think it was a
couple of hours it never was convincing
so yeah they they ran to the finish line
instead of just taking their time they
were the ones who asked for an
abbreviated final season and
they could have done it they could have
done every plot point roughly the same
way almost every plot point
over more episodes but they just didn't
want to and they
i've never seen a show lose so much
cultural goodwill so quickly that's all
anyone talked about for like 10 years
and now
i mean we're talking about it but
if you go to a dinner party and you're
like how about game of thrones
everybody's gonna be like what why yeah
why why are you i don't want to talk
about this anymore yeah yeah
it's interesting
yeah i i was i was thinking roughly the
same thing right like they obviously
you're right they had an ending and you
could you can see on paper how all of
the stuff that happens in the last
season could work look daenerys was
always a nut job who liked to barbecue
people with really little hesitation so
her going nuts is fine right but not
like that not like that not like this
no yeah she she just looks at a tower
and it's like and then she murders a
million people yeah it was it was way
too fast
so yeah so yeah so i think that's really
smart right keeping those guys away from
their new project so far away like a
restraining order yeah
legally do not let them there
i was thinking too for me my my mistake
to avoid is
this is a prequel this this show is
going to be set 300 years before the
events of game of thrones yes
don't
connect it to game of thrones yes i
couldn't agree more like just let it be
its own thing let it be its own thing
300 years is a long time
nice of the old republican
yeah right to the old republic exactly
right so so just go as far back as you
can in history tell a separate story if
you want to drop a couple seeds here
seeds there like oh this ancient sword
that shows up in game of thrones yeah
you can put that there no and you know
what that's a great point because like i
always joked that my personal nightmare
for the way game of thrones would end is
if like sam
looked right at the camera and was like
i wrote a book i think i'll call it a
game of thrones
that kind of happened in the finale he
wrote a book called a song of ice and
fire and i was watching it with a bunch
of people at my apartment and i got up
and i left my own living room i just was
like i can't i can't do this anymore i i
almost walked out of my apartment onto
the street just in fury um so my
nightmare for house of the dragon is
like they cut to like a blonde baby and
they're like i think we'll name her
daenerys or something like if they do
anything like that my head is going to
explode i agree with you completely keep
it separate let it let it coast on its
own strength right because i'm sure
there are going to be strengths
um this is a good story to tell but yeah
do not connect it to please god no yeah
make it make it a a spare connection if
if right right right
just like a wink a little winking nod a
wink and a nod yes exactly a dragon wink
yeah and then fire comes out of its
mouth i don't know exactly don't do that
none of that no tom no what about you
i'm ashamed to say it i i'm not like
terribly familiar with game of thrones
but while i was i was reading into this
uh
this prequel series that that they're
doing and uh it seems like they're
they're already making some really
interesting choices like they're
divorcing themselves from the source
material right at the beginning which uh
you know like like you were saying that
could lead to some really interesting
stories uh they have a they have a great
cast yeah they do
like really just remarkable actors matt
smith i would watch matt smith do most
things
yeah
so i think really as long as they don't
do anything stupid like for example put
him in a ridiculous wig they should be
fine
well luckily game of thrones never has
ridiculous wigs it would it would never
do such a thing i have some bad news for
you guys i'll show you after the video
um
but yeah i mean just like as like you
know we just we all just got done
watching black widow
um that was
kind of a prequel and we you know i
think we all agreed that that movie did
a pretty good job about not relying on
making these connections right like the
most the most connection we got between
uh black widow and then her next
appearance in infinity war was she got a
vest and a haircut and we didn't even
see the haircut we just saw some hair
dye and then the rest of the movie
happened right did get a hell of an
explanation for the best though it's a
pretty good one actually it's probably
the best one i've seen yeah
i needed it yeah i did a piece of
clothes that i didn't notice
that i didn't yeah that i didn't even
know we needed to talk about but like
yeah i mean and prequels are
like black widow was pretty good but
prequels can be tricky i mean we've
talked about solo on here before i mean
i don't think i even need to say
anything that rhymes with schmantum
schmenas
[Laughter]
grant and pennies that wasn't even a
good prime i'm sorry uh but i don't
think i don't need to bring up the star
wars prequels to be like this could go
horribly horribly wrong right i mean
this could just veer directly into this
most prequels are bad
right we all agree i'm actually i'm
sitting here racking my brain being like
is there a good prequel can i think of
one and not really
x-men first class is often cited as a
good prequel yeah i
remember liking it a lot of it
but i've never felt really compelled to
watch it again and the rest of that
franchise and it does and they had to
still do some kind of weird like
um alternate timeline thing to connect
to connect the franchise that right
started to the one that came after like
it still messed and then they ignored it
right so so overall like telling telling
the backstory telling the prequel story
is always this big gamble and so
i feel like in the fantasy realm you
have like the tragedy that is the hobbit
which i i know was based on its own book
but it's like
the hobbit's a 200 page book they made
it's got the free disease
three movies
and yeah um and they are
uh bad they're bad movies they're
they're not good um they they are such a
a weak sad ripoff of
the three movies that i deeply deeply
love
i love the original or the rings movies
i watch the extended editions a lot more
than i should say on on
tape but no yeah you could have hobbit
disease with this and it could suck and
i i would be really disappointed i'm
hopeful
that the backlash against the last
season of game of thrones has inspired
the team behind anything game of thrones
related to seriously step it up right
because it's not like
you know it's not like the end of return
of the king was horrible and everyone
hated it and they had to be like all
right guys we got to make the hobbit
really good and i'm hoping that everyone
over at house of the dragon is like all
right we cannot screw this up there's
too much there's too much on the line
for hbo for us for this show for this
legacy what have you yeah because the
other option is the game of thrones
broadway show and i don't see that being
anything that
will save anything
i'd watch it uh
i love it
i mean who do we get to do
no it's literally happening it's not
kidding
i thought you were joking okay that's so
much worse i was so excited game of
thrones stage play it's not a musical is
coming
stephen sondheim's game of thrones
i love this that's the only person who
could write it and who should write it
so if it were music
no sondheim we've got to get the dark
weirdo up in here give it to sondheim
disney tones unsettling lyrics let's go
but yeah i mean i think
game of thrones legacy is so deep in the
mud
maybe yes can save it i really hope it
does i mean
that's that's the question at this point
maybe that's the last question like is
there even any chance like hasn't
given well the winds of winter is never
coming out so this is the only shot
we can agree with that right yeah the
book is never coming out it's never
that's all over sorry yeah that guy's
not writing it he's literally writing
everything he's writing this change play
instead
it's not happening but yeah i think
you're right
is it possible brian yeah is it possible
for fans to actually want to come back
after they've been burned so hard by the
end of something that they invested
eight well it was eight years right
eight seasons
and two it was eight seasons and i mean
for the actors full decade of filming it
was almost a decade for for fans yeah
yeah rough stuff i don't know i mean
i'll check it out i'll check out house
of the dragon when it comes out but i
will not only be watching it yeah
but i'm i'm nervous
yeah i've been burned before i've lost
my ability to trust
fire and blood from an objective
third-party perspective this is
bizarre to watch i i recognize that
this is exactly what i do every time
that i talk about a franchise that i
love it's this is kind of me but
watching you guys go it sucked it was
terrible if the ending was really bad
they rushed it it was terrible yeah i
can't wait to watch what they do next
yeah uh
i will be paying 12 a month to do so
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
video
[Music]
you